ciao a tutte a tutti
conoscete la storia di pezzettino di leo
lionni pezzettino è un piccolo
quadratino arancione talmente piccolo
che è convinto di essere un pezzetto
mancante di un essere molto più grande
di lui e per tutta la storia pezzettino
cerca di capire di chi sia il pezzo
mancante
fino a che scopre di essere a sua volta
composto di tanti piccoli pezzettini e
quindi di avere un valore come
individualità e non necessariamente con
un pezzetto di qualcosa di più grande
perché vi storga raccontato sintetizzato
questa storia perché per certi versi la
storia di pezzettino è un po la storia
di tante piccole e micro imprese
la narrazione ufficiale vuole le piccole
imprese come dei pezzettini delle parti
di qualcosa di più grande è certo in una
logica di filiera e di rete ci sta ma la
piccola impresa in realtà è qualcosa di
più a qualcosa di più grande e
concettualmente è una singola unità con
un corredo genetico pazzesco e con tutti
gli attributi per giocare un ruolo
economico di primo piano e in questo mio
intervento io cerco di spiegarvi come
però faccio un attimo un passettino
indietro e mi presento sono mai anna e
gestisco una microimpresa qui a ravenna
noi siamo sul mercato da quasi 26 anni e
in questi anni però abbiamo cambiato
pelle o meglio per un'impresa è meglio
dire modello di business
almeno quattro volte e nella mia
esperienza ho capito una cosa che si può
rimanere piccoli micro e pensare e
soprattutto sognare in grande
si possono agganciare i trend mondiali e
al contempo mantenere la propria sede in
una piccola media città di provincia
oggi come diceva giulia oggi sia
necessario liberarsi da modelli e luoghi
comuni retaggio del passato il modello
di crescita continua ed infinita basato
sul consumismo e sullo sfruttamento a
sistemico e insostenibile delle risorse
non ha funzionato e ci ha reso fragili e
vulnerabili e soprattutto infelici è
vero che un'impresa ha la necessità di
crescere è quasi un bisogno fisiologico
e di crescere in continuazione
però la crescita non può e non deve
essere soltanto una crescita
quantitativa numerica una crescita di
fatturato
la crescita innanzitutto deve essere
soprattutto una crescita qualitativa
perché un'impresa che cresce
qualitativamente genera benessere e
ricchezza diffusi fa crescere qualità
per qualitativamente il proprio
territorio l'intera comunità comunità di
cui fa parte
e allora io mi sono domandata quali sono
i fattori che determinano la crescita
qualitativa di un'impresa come sono
queste quelle che io ho definito piccole
imprese toste le chiamò proprio pip per
per abbreviare cioè quelle che davvero
pur essendo piccole possono cambiare e
ridefinire il volto dei nostri territori
e l'intera economia
ho provato riassumerle clusterizzare in
sei punti sono innanzitutto imprese
locali ma con una forma mentis globale
cioè sono imprese innervate e ben
radicate sul territorio e allo stesso
tempo sono imprese aperte al mondo da
tanti anni si parla di economia glocale
senza però significativi cambi di
paradigma la pandemia ha dato certo una
bella spallata in questo è accelerato un
processo che oggi ci porta a dover
ripensare i nostri territori ad
immaginare di abitarli in maniera
diffusa purché chiaramente connessi
grazie a delle performanti
infrastrutture fisiche e digitali
ma la pandemia ci porta anche a
ripensare radicalmente i nostri stili di
vita e di lavoro
la nostra il modo in cui produciamo il
modo in cui consumiamo e ed è proprio
qui che le piccole imprese toste
le piccole imprese che ragionano in
maniera glocale fanno la differenza
perché sono parte viva e integrante di
un intera comunità e hanno proprio
insite nel loro dna
questi valori di circolarità e di
sostenibilità perché se ci pensate
progettare in ottica circolare non è
solo una questione di design ma si basa
soprattutto sulla consapevolezza di
sentire di poter fare la differenza è
più questa consapevolezza è più forte
forte cioè più riusciamo a toccare con
mano l'impatto delle nostre scelte e più
si acuisce il nostro tendere alla
circolarità in un vero e proprio circolo
virtuoso e questo credo che le piccole
imprese postero sappiano bene e poi
arriviamo al secondo punto il secondo
fattore io le definisco anti fragili
perché chi mi conosce sa che non amo
particolarmente la parola resiliente
perché la resilienza da un'idea di
qualcosa che semplicemente resiste agli
urti si adatta nuove condizioni che le
vengono imposte e quindi si adatta con
una certa inerzia e passività e quindi
io da quando ho conosciuto questo
termine anti fragilità l'ho sposato in
pieno nel senso è una definizione di
nassi in tale di qualche anno fa e
secondo me funziona e cosa significanti
fragile include sila e resilienza quindi
la capacità di adattarsi e di rinascere
ma l'anti fragilità un concetto molto
più ampio perché significa migliorare
grazie a agli urti cioè vuol dire
davvero fare delle crisi un'opportunità
e del fallimento una lezione di vita
chiaramente per farlo bisogna essere
innovativi e creativi ma direi che
l'anti fragilità racchiude tutto questo
tutti conoscerete il detto chi non fa e
chi non fa non sbaglia ed è verissimo ma
l'anti fragilità ci insegna che chi
sbaglia migliora sempre e vediamo anche
il terzo punto le piccole imprese toste
sono modulari come mattoncini lego
sanno perfettamente di dover puntare
tutto sulla propria unicità di doversi
distinguere emergere curare quindi i
propri fattori critici di successo e il
proprio valore aggiunto hanno un
carattere forte deciso e distintivo però
allo stesso tempo lavorano affinché
questa loro unicità questa singolarità
si incastri perfettamente con quella
delle altre imprese delle altre piccole
imprese come avviene con i mattoncini
lego perché una pitt una piccola impresa
tosta è consapevole di doversi mettere
in rete per fare progetti grandi e
ambiziosi e quando parlo di rete intendo
la vera rete non quella che si fa su
carta magari per partecipare a un bando
a una gara cioè la rete è il presupposto
indispensabile per costruire insieme e
significa anche sapersi dotare gli
obiettivi comuni di codici condivisi e
al contempo sa per contaminare gli altri
e farsi contaminare poi il quarto
fattore secondo me è fondamentale ed è
quello di saper coltivare talenti e
allevare eredi cioè in una piccola
impresa tosta il rapporto con i
collaboratori i neo assunti gli stagisti
è un rapporto di crescita e
arricchimento reciproco e continuo
perché queste piccole imprese sanno
leggere fra le righe di un inespressivo
curriculum europeo conoscono le domande
giuste da fare ad un colloquio e quindi
valorizzano si i percorsi di studio però
non ne rimangono intrappolate e anzi
sanno che a volte un dettaglio di un
curriculum un hobby può raccontare molte
più cose della persona che si candida di
quanto non faccia il titolo di un di
studio di un master conseguito e le
piccole imprese poste sono al contempo
maestre e allieve
io per esempio trovo veramente fonte
d'ispirazione quando ospito nella mia
azienda stagisti o alternati come noi
amiamo chiamare chi viene in alternanza
scuola lavoro perché dà anche l'idea di
essere un po un po fuori dagli schemi
come siamo noi un po pazzerello e siamo
consapevoli che queste persone che
ospitiamo non sono teste da riempire di
nozioni o braccia da tenere impiegate
con mansioni di basso profilo ma sono
veramente una preziosa occasione di
poter dialogare con delle persone che
vedono il mondo da una prospettiva
totalmente diversa e che soprattutto
indirizzeranno i mercati per i prossimi
30 40 anni perché spesso sono persone
giovanissime e un altro fattore
fondamentale è il fatto di sapersi
organizzare in maniera diversa dal
solito dalle imprese grandi cioè in una
piccola impresa le gerarchie sono spesso
schiacciate la cosiddetta catena del
comando è cortissima le gerarchie
verticali fanno spazio a delle sinapsi
orizzontali e spessissimo il
coordinamento e le responsabilità sono
delle variabili che vengono riassegnate
di progetto in progetto
io ho avuto la fortuna di crescere in
una famiglia davvero bella vitale
accogliente e con la famiglia abbiamo
costruito piano piano un'impresa quella
che gestisco adesso con i miei fratelli
e cerchiamo costantemente di ricreare in
azienda questo clima familiare che ci
portiamo dentro che è un clima informale
e che però è capace di diffondere
energia positiva e fiducia e ottimismo
tra chi lavora con noi che collabora con
noi
e concludo col sesto fattore le piccole
imprese toste sono alla continua ricerca
di innovazione di senso e di processo
sono entusiaste nel vero senso nel senso
più letterale della parola e qui mi
tocca citare mio padre fin da
piccolissima mi ha insegnato il
significato etimologico di questa parola
entusiasmo una parola che deriva dal
greco ed è composta da tre parole greche
the host e usi a cioè in di hall e senza
cioè si potrebbe tradurre con avere il
dio dentro essere arsi dal sacro cuore e
steve jobs direbbe più semplicemente
stay hungry stay foolish
e io a questo aggiungo un terzo stage
dei fan e la componente del divertimento
è fondamentale è fondamentale nella vita
in amore in famiglia sul lavoro
io i miei soci fratello e sorella
camilla e matteo quando eravamo piccoli
ci divertivamo tantissimo ridevamo dalla
mattina alla sera
e adesso riusciamo a ridere tantissimo
sul lavoro cui facendo cose serie veri
lavori siamo riusciti a ricreare il
nostro mondo infantile di giochi
avventure e spesso ci capita di perderci
nei lavori cioè però è quel perdersi
buono come quando da piccoli ci
inventavamo giochi e giocavamo tutto il
pomeriggio e poi arrivava la sera ti
chiamavano a cena e tu dicevi accidenti
io non vedo l'ora che sia domani per
ricominciare e questo auguro questo a
tutti tutti e tutte voi che vi succeda
nel lavoro e nella vita perché è una
cosa bellissima
grazie
[Applauso]